[Musique]
je m'appelle zhang j'ai 24 ans je vis à
pékin et ce qui suit est une partie de
mon histoire depuis que j'ai quitté ma
terre natale pour vivre une vie
meilleure
mes parents habitent dans un village de
mongolie intérieure à 8 heures de bus de
pékin ils sont paysans
il cultive du maïs du soja cela leur
apporte juste assez pour subvenir à
leurs besoins
peut-être 700 euros par an les bonnes
années mais il ne faut pas qu'ils
tombent malades ils n'auraient pas les
moyens de payer les médicaments
il voudrait que je me marie et que
j'habite au village avec eux mais je ne
veux pas de cette ville à travailler aux
champs c'est fatiguant on gagne peu
d'argent
c'est un métier dépassé
j'ai arrêté l'école à 16 ans à 17 ans en
2001 je suis parti pour pékin à la
recherche d'un travail
ma grande soeur travail est déjà là mon
premier boulot ça a été de vendre des
raviolis à la ga je ne gagne pas grand
chose 30 euros par mois
mais comme je pouvais manger les
raviolis que je vendais et que je
dormais chez mon patron ça suffisait
pour vivre un jour un homme est venu me
voir et m'a proposé de gagner deux fois
plus et je lui ai fait confiance
après avoir pris le train on a roulé
deux heures jusqu'à une briqueterie dans
la campagne
c'était une vraie arnaque je me suis
retrouvé enfermé la cuisine employer une
cinquantaine d'ouvriers avaient été
gardés par des chiens
on était forcés à travailler sans
salaire tous les jours 12 13 heures
parfois plus j'avais peur ça a duré un
mois comme ça un jour je suis tombé
malade
je suis resté mon dortoir personne même
surveiller j'en ai profité pour grimper
par dessus le mur j'ai couru pendant des
kilomètres jusqu'à une gav
je suis monté dans le train sans ticket
parce que j'avais trop peu nombreux
et puis je suis revenu chez mes parents
et je suis reparti quelques mois après
pendant des années j'ai été serveur
cuisinier dans des petits restos c'est
est monotone comme boulot et je gagnais
pas grand chose j'étais nourri logé et
je pouvais envoyer un peu d'argent mais
par an mais rien de plus alors il ya
quelques mois j'ai tout larguer vous
comprenez je rêve d'autre chose
j'aime le cinéma et je regarde souvent
des films dans les cafés internet
j'avais entendu parler des studios avec
un on m'avait dit que des producteurs et
des réalisateurs de films
venez recruter des figurants et des
acteurs devant les portes des studios
certains sont même devenus des stars
j'en ai parlé à mon cousin et à ma soeur
qui vivent à pékin il était contre ils
pensent que c'est pas possible de gagner
sa vie comme ça et qu'il n'y a aucune
chance de devenir connus finalement je
les ai pas écouté et j'ai quitté mon
boulot de serveur j'ai commencé à me
lever aux aurores il faut être à 5
heures du matin devant les studios si on
veut avoir une chance
on est souvent plus de 100 ou 200
personnes à attendre comme ça
la concurrence est difficile quand un
producteur débarque c'est la mêlée pour
être choisi
j'ai un peu arrêtez de me battre avec
les autres pour obtenir un rôle si un
producteur te veut il te trouves
il ya des gens qui passent et qui
prennent le numéro de téléphone
mais jamais personne ne m'a rappelé
[Musique]
lorsqu'une production a besoin de
beaucoup de figurants on est aligné les
filles d'un côté et les garçons de
l'autre ceux qui sont désignés sorte
durant les première fois c'est un peu
humiliant de ne pas être choisi
mais maintenant ça m'est égal avec un
peu de chance on peut travailler comme
ça deux ou trois jours dans une semaine
la première fois j'ai adoré ça enfiler
un costume être quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'on est très mal
payés en moyenne 2 à 3 euros pour une
journée de travail ça suffit pour se
nourrir mais pas plus
au début grâce à des économies
j'ai pu partager une petite chambre avec
d'autres figurants mais très vite c'est
devenu impossible
je n'avais pas les moyens maintenant je
vais dormir au café internet
on est beaucoup à faire ça on attend aux
heures du soir après cette heure là
c'est moins cher 50 centimes pour la
nuit avant 11 heures on marche dans la
ville
on va dans un parc où on attend devant
le café internet
[Musique]
quand c'est l'heure on va prendre un
fauteuil devant un écran
quant à une heure ou deux on joue à des
jeux où on regarde des films
moi j'aime bien les vieux classiques
comme le rêve du papillon rouge après on
essaie de dormir
c'est pas très confortable au début je
n'arrivais pas à dormir mais maintenant
je suis habituée à 4h30 on se réveille
on va se passer de l'eau sur le visage
dans les toilettes du café et on part
vers les studios
d'autres dorment au mcdo je les fais
aussi mais franchement j'aime pas trop
c'est encore moins confortable on peut
pas s'étendre
il ya beaucoup de lumière et en était de
les reconditionner très froid
en théorie on n'a pas le droit de dormir
là il faut consommer hamburgers ou des
frites
évidemment c'est trop cher pour nous
mais la plupart du temps le patron nous
laisse tranquilles tant qu'on gêne pas
les clients y en a d'autres qui dorment
dehors dans des tunnels sous le périph
ou devant les portes du studio j'ai
jamais fait ça c'est pas très sûr même
si on peut s'allonger
et puis la police peut débarquer
n'importe quand
[Musique]
c'est devenu de plus en plus difficile
parce qu'à moins de tournage
il ya quelques jours j'avais même pas
assez d'argent pour acheter à manger
heureusement ma grande soeur a pu m'en
donner un peu elle m'aide beaucoup
elle préférerait que j'ai un travail
plus stable mais elle me comprend elle
elle vend des produits de beauté pour
femmes dans un supermarché carrefour au
sud de pékin
c'est un bon job elle est plutôt bien
payé elle habite une petite chambre pas
loin du supermarché
j'aime pas beaucoup son quartier parce
que c'est pas très propre
son mari et son fils de 4 ans à eux
habitent au village elle s'entend plus
très bien avec son mari mais je sais que
son fils lui il lui manque beaucoup
comme moi elle préfère vivre à pékin et
puis il faut qu'elle gagne de l'argent
[Musique]
on aime bien se retrouver tous les deux
mais ça n'arrive pas souvent parce que
le trajet pour aller la voir pendant au
moins une heure en tout cas on s'entend
mieux qu'au village et j'ai décidé
d'arrêter d'attendre devant les studios
parce que j'ai pas eu de boulot depuis
au moins dix jours il ya moins de
tournage en ce moment mais peut-être que
je suis pas assez grand ou pas assez bon
pour être embauché j'ai pas mis beaucoup
de temps à retrouver un petit boulot
après avoir cherché un peu sur internet
j'ai marché dans le quartier autour des
studios
j'ai vu un hôtel je suis entré et ils
m'ont tout de suite embauché à la
réception j'ai eu ce boulot grâce à mon
expérience dans la restauration ils
m'ont donné un uniforme un peu trop
grand
quand il fait chaud c'est pas
confortable j'ai qu'une hâte c'est de
pouvoir l'enlever
le boulot est pas très bien payé 80
euros par mois mais on est nourri et
logé
je vois des gens mâché fait plutôt sympa
je m'entends bien avec mes collègues on
est en dortoir lui dans chaque dortoir
dans des lits superposés
il ya une bonne ambiance entre nous
c'est pas très propre mais ça peut aller
en tout cas c'est déjà mieux qu'au café
internet
[Applaudissements]
je vais continuer ce boulot pendant
quelques temps il me déplaît pas mais
plus tard quand j'aurai un peu
d'économies je retournerai devant les
studios
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]